uh first of all congratulations on the
movie uh so one of the things I'm so I
have a lot of questions four minutes I
don't know how I'm going to do it uh you
were turning into a very talented
director and I'm wanting to know what
did you borrow from Matthew vaugh
because he has a very unique style and
he's a very unique filmmaker that you
are now going to take with you to your
future endeavors one of the uh main
reasons why I wanted to do this movie
was because I wanted to understand how
Matthew shot his action what he does is
um beyond what uh what you know is
typically seen these days and um and
getting to see his relationship with
very sadly the the late Brad Allen um
and then you know because Brad set all
of this up and all the choreography and
then um and then passed away very
suddenly and so it was all on Matthew
and his team to to to execute it and so
so I I learned a lot a lot a lot a lot
about how he does it but also how he
does it under you know very difficult
circumstances and it was impressive and
just also his ability to have a vision
for something and pivot whenever needed
like if there's a plan and he he thinks
it's not working he'll shift it and that
was that was pretty thrilling and in
large part because he paid for the movie
himself yeah that Matthew as a yeah
that's a whole another thing you know
what I mean um so I I definitely want to
ask there's a little bit of playful
question there a lot of rumors have been
online that Taylor Swift is the real
lway and so what what are you both
thinking when you hear stuff like that
and uh I just have to ask well there's
no proof that she's not Ellie
Conroy but there's also no proof that
she is that's all I'm going to say I
think Matthew has come out and
officially said that it's not Taylor swi
I like to just stir the pot a little bit
but isn't that what a spy would say
anyway
yes so one of the things though and it's
hard to talk about this movie is this
thing is loaded with twists and turns so
I'm so curious for both of you what is
it like reading a script like this for
the first time and how much is your
Adrian or Matthew giving you a heads up
saying expect twists and turns or they
just saying en enjoy this one oh it was
just an enjoy this one it was Matthew
emailing me directly um you know none of
the Reps had the script or anything and
he was just like I would love to you
know have you take a read and see what
you think and and it we both talked
about this it's was Jason's script Jason
fuches who's the writer and producer of
this
film just it wrote something impeccable
and just every like three pages it was
like like you know and it's how you feel
when you're watching the movie it really
translated it's it's like a ride I did
have to read uh some of the pages twice
because are they he's really going to do
oh my God the audac it of the filmmaker
to say I'm going to do this it's like oh
my God and you go off into Fantasy Land
just reading it and um anytime you're
you're able to put a cast together like
like he did I I was thrilled to be a
part of it last question for you you
seeing the shooting schedule you know
what's coming up what's the day you have
circled in terms of I cannot wait to
film this or oh my God how are we going
to film this oh God honestly it was on
the regular it was like tomorrow and
then another tomorrow and then another
tomorrow where it was it every single
day had an was so ambitious so ambitious
on this movie and um and so we would
start every day sort of being like okay
how are we going to do this how are we
going to get there and lo and behold you
know we would and it was always because
of Matthew's determination and his
vision and his strengths as a producer
as well he's incredibly ambitious as a
filmmaker and a director but he knows
how to back it up by making it happen
and that's a special skill that that
most folks don't have you know you have
either the creative the Visionary and
it's like oh I don't want to know what
it costs and then there's the like but
this doesn't make sense to do it and
Matthew is somehow able to to combine
both of those talents to make the
impossible possible and and how lucky
are we as audiences to to get to
to experience that kind of spectacle for
me it was uh there was one of the big
twists in in the middle of the movie
early on and I was excited to be able to
to be a part of that big twist because
it's it's one of those moments that the
audience goes oh my gosh and uh it's
always fun to be a part of that to fool
them but then you can track it and you
go oh my God I see how this came about
won't say anything
more